the Florida I am the little school
student from Washington State as you
already know our environment is
threatened by human right now and it's
time to make a change but a lot of
people don't see the strap or they don't
want to make change the question is how
can we get to influence humans to
protect a planet in order some important
actions we can do start right now to
save the world I know it's hard but I
just hope that you could give me some
clue
thank you very much Victoria Victoria
you are the key to the future my friend
so here's the thing you're live in
Washington State you know I live in
Seattle for many years I love wash and
go Seahawks I'm right there my friend go
Mariners now you are in middle school
you are the future people will tell you
that but they're not kidding so what we
want you to do is influence your parents
and make sure they vote voting is the
most important thing for us especially
this year and I want your parents I want
you to encourage your parents to take
the environment into the account when
they pick people to vote for now your
governor jay Inslee is an acquaintance
of mine and he's a big environmental
show he wrote a book Apollo's fire and
so on it's about the future what people
are doing to take care of the
environment and have energy produced
electricity especially renewably without
having to burn fossil fuels so it's it's
up to you to influence your parents yes
very important to recycle your plastic
and your paper very important to in also
in Washington State I'm not sure exactly
where you live but you can recycle your
food waste along with your yard waste
and that becomes compost which nourishes
nourishes our farms which in turn
produces food part of the mythic cycle
of life so you can encourage your
parents to do that but we need big ideas
big changes we
in Washington State there's enormous
opportunities for wind turbines and
enormous opportunities for photovoltaics
for solar cells that take sunlight and
make it right into electricity
especially in eastern Washington so you
can be part of that and you're in middle
school that is a turning point for most
people in their science education so I
hope you Victoria will apply yourself in
science class in biology physics
chemistry and there's probably another
class you might have about planetary
science or astronomy in earth science
and the other thing Victoria is really
important especially for girls is
algebra and I just want to tell you al
Jabar is this this way to think it
trains your brain to think in this way
that enables you to imagine to imagine
things to to accept that you don't know
the answer but you're going to find it
and so I really encourage you I just
tell you that I took hours where you
just have to practice there's no way
around it you just got to do it over and
over to you to get comfortable with it
and you can do it and by the way when
you're a girl in middle school you're
kind of better at everything than the
boys now that'll change in the next four
or five years I mean you'll even out but
right now just go with it my friend
go with it make sure you learn algebra
learn science so that you if you choose
to be a scientists or better yet an
engineer which is a profession in which
you use science to solve problems and
make things that you can lead the world
in these new technologies but right now
do those things at home that make a
little that make an important difference
at home recycling not wasting energy not
wasting clean water and make sure your
parents take the environment into
account and make sure they vote Thank
You Victoria go get them